what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu and now we are
officially one week away from marvel
studios's panel at d23 it is next
saturday september 10th and something
very interesting and very very curious
has happened today a lot of names have
been thrown out there that have
apparently been cast over at marvel
studios and they come from a verified
twitter account and some insiders are
retweeting this tweet which would
seemingly make it appear like this
casting report is true however it's very
interesting because the report is coming
from somebody not inside of our industry
but like i mentioned major scoopers and
some big outlets have backed up the
casting report and there are some truly
big names on this casting report and one
of those big names is henry cavill
superman himself so it looks like we
could actually have our fantastic
forecast already and possibly even some
x-men and apparently according to this
reporter if his information is accurate
we're supposed to get an announcement at
d23 in a week from today so let's go
over this report let's go over all of
these different actors and which roles
they could be playing in the marvel
cinematic universe and of course if
you're new be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest mcu
news okay so first things first this
report is coming from somebody named
emmett kennedy he does have a verified
twitter account but here's the catch
he's a broadcaster on talksport 2 he has
racing's number one podcast final for a
long pod and when i say racing i mean
horse racing he's been on cnn rte itv
he's a commentator and he is a voice
over actor so that's the catch he
doesn't actually have anything to do in
our industry although he does seem to be
credible at his own job that makes it
really weird it's a weird report because
it's coming from somebody who is
typically credible but has nothing to do
with marvel studios or anything in the
mcu but as i mentioned his tweet which
we're about to go over has been
retweeted by some big insiders so here
is the tweet and list of names that he
said is joining marvel studios his tweet
says i'm reliably informed that marvel
studios have signed epic talent for
phase 5. here's the list john boyega
henry cavill jody comer daisy edgar
jones john krasinski goncarlo esposito
and denzel washington now the tweet ends
by saying to be announced with some on
stage by kevin feige at d23 expo 2022
fantastic four she-hulk x-men he had a
follow-up tweet that said bring on d23
expo 2022 now these are obviously huge
names and of course we're going to be
talking about the roles that they could
possibly be playing but first let's talk
about credibility now i don't know
anything about emmett kennedy he seems
to be respectable in his own industry
and of course it's always possible that
you can meet other people who know
information that could be legitimate
having said that take this with a grain
of salt because he's not in our industry
however like i said some big insiders
like daniel rpk have retweeted the list
that he has put out there giving him
credit for it daniel rpk is known for
his leaks and he's been very accurate
very lately also geek vibes nation
recently put out that same list also
giving credit to emmett and skyler
schuler over at the dis insider who i
know is very careful about what he says
online says that daisy edgar jones as
sue storm wouldn't that be fantastic
with a little smirk face so it seems
like this list or at least some people
on this list could be legitimately cast
for some roles in the x-men and the
fantastic four and marvel studios now i
also want to add that john boyega of
course is from the star wars franchise
grace randolph recently said that marvel
studios was looking at somebody from the
star wars franchise so this also goes
with that report as well now who could
these actors be playing well no offense
to john boyega but i don't see him as mr
fantastic or the human torch so that
leads me to believe that he could be
playing the thing if he could be cast
for the fantastic four if he's been cast
for the x-men well there's actually a
lot of people that he could be really
good at and actually seeing john boyega
gon carlo esposito and denzel washington
on this list leads me to believe that we
could have not necessarily a days of
future past movie but maybe like a young
magneto and an older magneto type of
thing where john boyega could play a
younger magneto and maybe giancarlo or
denzel playing the older magneto i
actually don't think they'll do that but
that's kind of the vibe i get here but
like i said there are many x-men that he
could play he could play night crawler
he could play a version of gambit havoc
saber-tooth there's a lot of different
x-men characters that he could play now
like i mentioned giancarlo esposito
could be playing magneto as well however
he has mentioned recently and very
publicly that he would love to play
professor x and i think a lot of people
have expressed that they would really be
on board with this now if he were to be
cast as professor x and the fact that
denzel washington is on this list i want
to say that denzel washington would be
playing magneto however i think denzel
is a little bit too old for the
character and i also don't think that
he'll want to commit to the franchise
for the next 10 to 15 plus years which
leads me to believe that he might
actually be playing a villain role now
this could be a fantastic four villain
this could be an x-men villain or simply
a marvel villain in general but of
course i am not against denzel
washington joining the mcu in the
slightest i think it would be really
cool to see him there and marvel studios
really has been getting some huge big
name actors recently we've gotten
angelina jolie salma hayek michelle yo
tony lau michelle pfeiffer michael
douglas it's a big list it's not a small
list of big actors we've had really
really big actors in the mcu and denzel
washington could be the next one now
jody comer who you might know from the
movie free guy she was supposedly on a
list of actors who could play sue storm
however skyler shuler's tweet seems to
imply that daisy edgar jones is going to
be playing sue storm so if that's the
case then jody comer could be up for an
x-men role and i mean there's just a ton
of different characters that she could
play she could play rogue she could play
kitty pride she could even play jean
grey it's not that hard to dye your hair
red there's just a whole bunch of
characters that she could play and i
really hope that she is cast for some
type of role in the mcu because i truly
enjoyed her in free guy and i actually
personally think that she could make a
very good emma frost now we do have two
names left and they're kind of big but
they're also kind of controversial and
we'll start with henry cavill i
personally think that he would make an
amazing sentry now there's been rumors
going around for a while that henry
cavill could play century or hyperion
now honestly he would fit both of these
characters perfectly they are basically
kind of variants of superman
specifically hyperion hyperion in the
comics was the only survivor of the race
of the eternals from a dying world of
course we know the eternals but they did
kind of change their origin in the mcu
as an adult he would grow up to become a
superhero known as hyperion and he would
be on the team of superheroes known as
the squadron supreme now here's where
things get interesting and connect to
the mcu his universe would eventually
start to collide with another universe
otherwise what is known as incursion
that has been mentioned in doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness and
in the secret wars comic line is kind of
the main event that happens that brings
all of the universes together leaving
only one universe that's what happens to
century his universe is destroyed and
he's left in a void but of course he
goes on to fight with the avengers and a
bunch of other different heroes as well
and his powers are basically like
superman's he has superhuman speed
strength flight he doesn't need to eat
his skin is basically impenetrable but
he does have superhuman healing as well
he has x-ray vision he has enhanced
hearing but he does have things like
cosmic energy manipulation which is a
little bit different from superman but
basically what this means is that he has
atomic vision meaning that he can
project beams of highly concentrated
heat from his eyes kind of like superman
does so hyperion is essentially marvel's
superman now century is essentially the
same the origin story is way different
however century's name is robert
reynolds and he gets the power of a
thousand sons by breaking into an
unknown laboratory because he was a meth
head and he ingests a serum now this
serum was meant to be a duplicate of the
super soldier serum that captain america
took however it was supposed to be a
thousand times stronger robert took it
and became the century now he was a meth
addict before however he really cleans
his act up once he becomes a superhero
and he ends up fighting alongside the
fantastic four they fight doctor doom
and they defeat him he becomes a mentor
for spider-man actually and he fights
alongside a lot of other heroes he has a
lot of powers that hyperion has except
he has some really cool things about him
as well he is basically immortal he can
resurrect himself he has clairvoyance so
he's basically psychic he has matter
manipulation and can actually share his
powers with other people and he can
actually turn invisible and of course he
has all of those other superpowers like
flight superhuman speed and
vulnerability and a lot of other cool
powers as well so again kind of like a
superman and since superman is played by
henry cavill in the dc universe i think
we know that henry cavill would make a
good century or hyperion in the mcu now
the controversial thing about that is
that he would simply be switching from
dc to marvel almost playing the same
role and it would kind of be a marvel vs
dc thing but hey i'm all for him joining
the mcu and the last one is john
krasinski now this is controversial
because it seemingly appeared that john
krasinski was only cast as mr fantastic
strictly for multiverse of madness and
not the main mcu mr fantastic kevin
feige had already stated that it was
sort of a fan service to cast john
krasinski in multiverse of madness so we
didn't think that he would be the main
one however he is on this list so it
looks like he could indeed still be
playing the main mr fantastic unless
they cast him for another role which
would be very interesting but i would be
very curious to see who he played
however i would love him to play mr
fantastic so let me know what you think
about all of these actors in this report
and who you think they'll be playing
leave your comments down below don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest news for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof